[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i didn't realize how many people were
like i grew up in a small town like we
just had you know it was like probably
maybe 70 percent white 30 percent black
and it was pretty poor town and i
remember going to africa was the first
country i ever went to and i was like
it's a continent it's not a country yeah
and i remember thinking holy [ __ ] dude
all these people are going to be in
heaven that's what i never realized and
i was like [ __ ] because i always
pictured heaven like just the people
from my town were going to be there
and then i remember going to this place
and being like holy [ __ ] man what are we
going to do now in heaven it's going to
be packed that was my first thought do
you believe in heaven yeah and i thought
when we died dude it's going to be
packed and so then suddenly had all this
anxiety like you know like um
i guess not anxiety but just like you
know like [ __ ] man i gotta rethink
you know what you're my afterlife yeah
and so i was like um yeah
is there a room for africans in your
your afterlife and there's a lot of room
for them you got to see how many are
coming
for you got to see how many are but i
think i have like a thing yeah it's like
i don't like i have a tough time working
i just think i have a tough time working
with other people sometimes you know
which is one of the reasons why i got
into comedy anyway
you know what this is i would say get
over that yeah get over yourself and get
over that because there's a lot of great
people in this business and you're going
to miss out
and uh i don't know
no no what you'll say your loved ones
will save money on the funeral costs
because no one's going to go so there's
not going to be too many [ __ ] snacks
they got to put together
i know i can put an audience in myself
i'm not enough to spend half the budget
paying some lady to get
you know to guarantee a seating
times on that i got burned a couple
times yeah like they somehow figure out
what your budget is yeah you could have
eight dollars or 80 million dollars and
their budget's gonna come in like two
cents below
we can shoot this special for 7.99 and
then they find out you have it you know
not like you get 8 million but so you
had 8 million they'd be like uh yeah we
did win what he wants it's going to be
7.99999 [ __ ] million dollars and it's
just like
yeah they put all the egyptians in the
crowd it's weird it's gross the way that
it was it i stand up is such a weird
thing where it's totally respected and
completely disrespected it has this
thing that where it's just like when you
meet people who aren't comedians so many
people say oh my god i can't believe you
got the balls to do that i would never
do that but whenever they show a
comedian it's always the worst
like hey this guy knows what i'm talking
about like a lampshade on their head and
we're just this loud obnoxious on off
stage just oh my god get this guy the
[ __ ] away from me you know what
fascinates me is like basically the
first 16 or 17 years of my life when i
never i mean i took a couple sips of my
you know stole a beer here there for my
dad but i never really went out and
tried to get drunk until i was like 16
or 17. but i went for like a decade and
a half
like i was straight edge you know what i
mean and but the thing was oh you told
kid you were straight edge you're like i
don't know no no no just thought of
being a kid it's not like your first 10
years of your life you're like [ __ ]
playground man i need a drink that's
it's just not where your world is at i'm
not saying i'm never gonna [ __ ] drink
again but i just i i had i had to like
i kind of just had to like step back and
just be like all right because you know
the reality is i got a kid so i just
didn't want to be that i'm like you
don't get drunk when your kids around my
[ __ ] lou grant with a bottle of
whiskey in the remember that on mary
tyler moore's show she'd have a rough
day and she'd come in and i don't
remember the whole show i can explain it
to you yeah if i could explain it
like a guy just i don't know what that
is all right
i don't know i don't know and the second
i started to explain like i don't know
the whole show all right i get it i get
it i believe is that comic add like i
don't even [ __ ] i'm not into it i
don't want to hear it i got it your show
go ahead continue i remember uh all
right let's talk about old shows then
we don't have to i just was it was a
funny how you [ __ ] you bailed twice
on that patty duke made me feel like an
[ __ ] like that was the 15th time i
[ __ ] brought it up
sorry no mary tyler moore
one of the great ensemble [ __ ] cast
of all time i do know she just died
recently
uh yeah i mean i was gonna bring up a
more positive story about the show but
yeah it's the second time
i bring up [ __ ] george michael losing
an aids event huh some sort of gay thing
well i didn't say gay bro but why did
you say aids because he had aids man no
he didn't did he
i jesus no he didn't well people have
been saying he did
i think you are confusing it with gay
no i'm not i didn't know he was gay i
knew that apparently you got aids in a
park that's what i heard and oh he blew
a guy in a porta potty and got busted
for lewd activity
and then you know he you know had a
little [ __ ] you know he liked getting
a little buzzed at the end of the
[ __ ] day and maybe it got away from
him i think that's what happened but
like what i would like to focus on was
how amazing his voice was and how
talented he was and i played this
performed and stood in the same spot
that this guy did yeah that's what the
point was not what he died of yeah oh
wait a minute and it was what happened
in your life
who'd you lose early on you're really
into death well no i mean i remember
listening you don't want to get to know
mary tyler or more because you're afraid
she's going to leave you too
i remember listening to uh george
michael on the school bus when i would
go to school and i felt like and i would
always sit by myself you feel like you
were gonna catch aids by doing that some
sort of airborne
hiv through the [ __ ] radio
i mean bro i was holding it up to my ear
you know
i couldn't feel my ass in a ruthless
school bus one of the the wind born
radio aids was going to get me in
singapore airlines where they still have
like the hot chick [ __ ] stewardesses
which for some reason that became like
discontinued yeah like this [ __ ]
thing dude it's the greatest thing ever
oh and they all if you watch them in the
airport they'll move like a school of
fish almost they like well they're all
in a group in formation they're all in
like it's like a young beautiful
military day i know and you're just
sitting there like it makes you happy to
be on the airplane god forbid yeah god
forbid and then people just sit there
all right because she has to be
beautiful yes i mean that can't that's
[ __ ] part of nature yeah it's nate
that people are trying to act like that
isn't a [ __ ] thing anyway so
oh nature is anything i had to get a
work permit to go there and then when i
went there i had to get them to sign a
piece of paper so it was okay for me to
leave and i didn't like that yeah at all
like almost like checking in for school
or something like that no i had to go to
like this [ __ ] embassy thing and they
wouldn't let the promoter come in there
and i was sitting there with some chick
from afghanistan and we're both looking
at each other like are they gonna let us
out of here one of us and and there was
like um
you know when they do this thing where
they don't when you ask them a question
they don't
nod yes or shake no like they kind of do
like oh yeah they do that double lock
they do this [ __ ]
yeah because i was like all right so i
got this piece of paper i'm doing my
show tonight and then i'm going to the
airport and i'll be able to get out if i
show him this and she was just like
oh yeah doing this it's like lady i'm on
the other side of the [ __ ] globe
yeah what do you guys own me now what's
going on here am i in that [ __ ] with
that guy tape the drugs to him what the
[ __ ] was that movie i don't know what
the [ __ ] it was
women in uh no this is before you were
you this is when you were real young um
midnight express oh you haven't seen
yeah you guys don't know that with tom
hanks just file that under mary tyler
moore yeah oh that's polar express is
what i'm thinking of yeah polar express
i've never been a helicopter i've been
in like oh i've been in a black hawk one
time actually and i was doing a show in
vaz basra or something and i got a blow
job and an unsecured airfield from a
female
and uh in the middle of the night in a
blackhawk helicopter praise god brother
well there you go so yes he's been in a
helicopter so i have been in one but
only with a gun you know only when
people had guns do you keep a weapon on
yours or no on what in your
uh
i don't know if you have a helicopter if
you rent a helicopter i really have to
answer that he knows god damn well i
don't have a weapon why are you doing
this
you don't
you don't have a gun i don't think
that's i don't think that's
obtuse really to think you might have a
weapon in there with you
think about it yeah think about it okay
you think about it
all right
just a small gun dude as a hand piece
yeah no okay
fine fine bill
that's just a [ __ ] ridiculous
question i thought you're bringing
hoosie up there when you flip
fly as a hobby i don't know it's too
depressing to watch i don't understand
news junkies oh why why you would
[ __ ]
do that to yourself and the [ __ ]
stories that they show my god it's just
like i can't i want to [ __ ] see this
it's all sad stuff here's sad stuff that
you can't do anything about and now you
know it yeah enjoy yourself try not to
drink tonight
or go to mcdonald's don't go to
mcdonald's yeah all right here we go
let's get a little this is the first
person wearing a shirt i believe
that's our audience
all right
hey bill hey theo this is marissa from
raleigh north carolina
and uh so bill i heard you say on i
believe it was joe rogan's podcast that
you really liked the film once upon a
time in hollywood and you've seen it
several times and i know theo said that
he walked out halfway through it um so i
was just wondering maybe if you could
talk about why you loved it so much and
theo why you walked out halfway through
it
anyway gang gang
well this is where bill and i don't talk
anymore after this no no i if you didn't
like it you didn't like it i absolutely
[ __ ] loved it i heard on your podcast
you said that you loved it oh my god
dude it's the best work uh leo's
i mean brad pitt's great first time you
watch it i was just like i want to be
like brad pitt's the guy i want to be
yeah and then the second time i watched
i was like oh my god i'm just like leo's
character i have an emotional [ __ ]
mess
well i don't know what part you walked
out and i walked out after they went to
that house for the first time after they
met the old guy and they were in the
yard and then his car was had a flat
tire and at that point i was like i got
to get out of here i don't know what
these guys are doing you know i felt
like it was just kind of a waste of
i don't know it just i couldn't get into
it and i didn't know what was going on
and it made me feel uncomfortable it's
like i got to get out of here because i
started to feel like everybody knows
what's going on and i don't know what's
going on you know i guess yeah that's
that's for you and the therapist buddy
yeah if that happens to you at the
[ __ ] movies if you think the whole
movie the whole movie theater gives a
[ __ ] about whether
no i don't think
are you making like audible noises that
you do oh
whoa
oh
oh my gosh that's the only way they
would know
[ __ ] man i don't know i was so [ __ ] up
mandy yeah you do yeah you did i really
did it you do i don't know the insider
trackman you do i really didn't though
i really did it man yeah i don't get
into the [ __ ] real housewife aspect
of sports i don't give a [ __ ] right
about right that's not who that's not
what we're there for as well yeah i want
to watch the game i don't want to sit in
a [ __ ] tailgate [ __ ] parking lot
talking to some [ __ ] about like
somebody's what the [ __ ] did you see
what he did in the dairy queen it's like
i don't give a [ __ ]
isn't that for the local authorities
what are gonna be some gum shoe here now
what do you think about the scandal
yeah it's like i'm a sports fan i don't
think i just [ __ ] watch this [ __ ] and
react to stuff that has nothing to do
with my life and i enjoy it i've seen
most of his films do you ever see
founder
uh is that about the dog that dies nope
that's about mcdonald's oh though yeah
oh my god yeah
you saw that right you like that one so
good there you go you didn't walk out
you didn't feel like see that i
understand fast food
i like this one
too much talking can't handle
man it was a bummer it was some of it
was a bummer but someone would just move
the dates and i'll just feel better when
i get there but i was i was just like
experienced like a ton of stress man
burnt
out you know i've been on the same tour
for this hour for almost over a year now
um
dude bands tour for like four years and
then [ __ ] go right back in the studio
make another one and keep going you got
to toughen up man yeah you're right huh
yeah what do i do camouflage hat looking
like a [ __ ] backwoods guy all tough
and [ __ ] you can't handle doing your
hour again i mean come on man
suck it up
[ __ ] man i think i need some blood
transfusions or something
i really do i don't know what happened
no but it's not bad if it there's the
other side too where you're getting run
down and you don't listen to it and then
you get sick
so there's always that or work yourself
to death which i've seen a few people do
in this business literally died yeah so
there's definitely you know
well you're in touch with your feelings
that's that's good
yeah man i got too many of them i think
if you beat me open uh just a lot of
feelings sometimes would come out too
many you know i think i'm yeah somehow i
got caught up in some of that feeling
generation you know yeah maybe my
perspective sometimes i think well one
thing definitely is i've made more money
even just in the past year i've finally
started making money you know and it's
definitely been like yeah sometimes even
in the beginning of this evening he's
gonna start yelling at himself in the
mirror like leo
and the part before you walked out
was it really [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah
oh he yells at himself in the mirror
it's one of my favorite seats
uh maybe i got to watch it again yeah
you you yeah you don't have to i don't
want to force well i'm not going to
watch it because you want me to watch it
but i'll watch it maybe because maybe i
did miss something you know i just at a
certain point i'm just like my favorite
part of it was that brad pitt had a
little bit of like a hitch in his walk a
little bit if you notice that what about
leo with the with the speech impediment
that only happened off i love how you
just dismissed that yeah oh my god
that's amazing that's what's amazing
about when somebody makes something like
people's reaction like oh my god this is
the greatest thing ever somebody else
hey [ __ ] walked out
i get nervous the whole movie theater
was listening to my inner thoughts
they care they care this much about me i
don't think they care i [ __ ] care
in my head i care too much when i put
the hat on that means i gotta go that's
fine i wanna show you my truck all right
all right so we can bond on something we
can agree we we missed the mark on
mary tyler moore yep you brought it up
family man have you seen that movie i've
seen family guy
what about uh the nice
guys oh you got to see that
okay you got to see that one that's a
funny one oh that's a nice guys no i
don't know i think you're you're looking
down you got you all out you got your
job it's very confrontational i'm
feeling like you're not liking my
suggestions i just like you you like to
america
in hollywood this guy's dead to me he's
dead to me
just to let you know i can't hear your
inner thoughts so don't get all [ __ ]
weirded out
i just walk out crazy i feel like you're
in my head man super quick
i really do you if you got grandfathered
in and you were cool and then once you
anything after that was like no who the
[ __ ] is this
this person needs to be terminated did
you ever uh you ever donated sperm or
anything like that when you were coming
up as a comedian nope and i don't have a
gun in my helicopter
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]